e
[Musique]
pas fait
car aux affaires pk et
là
je viens de croiser mon envie de
travailler et c'est confirmé on va quand
même en droit
[Musique]
d'attendre d'un story torre paix attend
là bas historique
bon ok j'ai peut-être été un petit peu
léger sur les réseaux sociaux ces
derniers temps mais c'est parce que je
prépare elle à vannes la vanne as du
siècle
accroche toi t'es pas prêt est ce que
quelqu'un qui va aux toilettes avec une
personne qu'elle qu'ovide est considéré
comme kaka contacte
alors pas de la bombasse savait pas le
coût de ce maître de trois semaines aux
verts 1 à l'aller des proches démolir on
les entend moins le texte le texte le
texte alors maintenant la lie qu'on la
partage on la fait tourner elle devient
virale et puis on est content ok elle
est chère
[Rires]
[Musique]
mais
donc
il
[Musique]